hey it's david2 and welcome back to
what's new in networking where we cover
well what's new in networking today i'll
provide some new updates for the network
intelligence center so let's dive right
in
[Music]
networks are at the foundation of an
environment you need a pane of glass
that can provide a multitude of tools to
troubleshoot diagnose and monitor your
environment
network intelligence center provides
that single console for managing google
cloud network visibility monitoring
verification and optimization today
there are currently four modules in the
network intelligence center network
topology connectivity tests performance
dashboard and firewall insights today
we'll be covering new enhancements for
the connectivity test and the
performance dashboard diving right in
connectivity test is a configuration and
route analyzer that lets you diagnose
connectivity issues in your vpc network
due to a misconfiguration or due to
missing routes when analyzing network
configurations connectivity test uses an
abstract state machine to model how a
vpc network should process packets
google cloud processes the packet in
several logical steps
previously connectivity test was purely
a configuration analyzer with the launch
of dynamic reachability verification we
introduced live data plane analysis
dynamic verification tests connectivity
by sending multiple trace packets from
the source endpoint to the destination
the dynamic verification results show
you the number of probes
the number of probes that successfully
reach the destination and a reachability
status the status is determined based on
how many probes were successfully
delivered reachability is more than 95
percent unreachable is zero percent and
partial reachable is between zero and
ninety five percent
in addition to showing how many packets
were successfully delivered dynamic
verification also shows median and 95th
percentile one-way latency information
the last topic today will be the
performance dashboard performance
dashboard gives you the visibility into
the performance of your project's
resources as well as the performance of
the entire google cloud network
it will provide you with packet loss and
latency details so how does it work
performance dashboard runs workers on
physical hosts that house your vms
these workers insert and receive pro
packets that run on the same network as
your traffic because the workers run on
the physical host and not on the vms
these workers do not consume vm
resources and the traffic is not visible
to your vms
what about latency for latency
latency is measured by tcp packets based
on the sample of your actual traffic
latency is calculated as the time that
elapsed between sending the tcp sequence
number and receiving the corresponding
act that contains network rtt and tcp
stack related delay the ui shows latency
as the median of all the relevant
measurements
in the project performance view
performance dashboard shows packet loss
and latency for zones where you have
compute engine resources for your
project this release introduces a
performance dashboard for all of google
cloud the dashboard presents the overall
google cloud metrics for each possible
google cloud zone pair
it displays the current status of google
cloud network and lets you compare
performance across all of google cloud
to the performance observed in your
projects
similar to project view performance will
be shown via summary charts and heat
maps for both packet loss and latency
and you have the ability to review six
weeks of history so that's all we have
for this episode of what's new in
networking check out the links below to
learn more about network intelligence
center and stay tuned for the next
episode of what's new in networking
you